[Musique]
je vais commencer par retirer ma montre
parce qu'il s'agit de gérer de temps
j'ai quinze minutes n'est ce pas on
m'accorde 15 minutes pour parler
d'immortalité
déjà que tout est biaisé 15 minutes
j'avais commencé par me dit en entrant
ici à 13 heures que le temps ne
passerait pas
et le temps passé pour confirmer que
nous sommes des mortels des mortels qui
parle d'une mortalité
je sais pas si c'est possible
15 minutes est ce que je pourrais parler
du motel temps c'est plus de temps je
vais je ne sais pas mais dans tous les
cas je pense que tous ceux qui sont
succédé sur cette scène en confirmé
qu'il est possible de rêver et donc de
croire qu'on peut traverser le temps qui
nous est imparti et même marque de temps
et aller au delà du temps le rêve de
chacun d'entre nous c'est certainement
donc de fait comme l'a dit samuel non
pas être dans ce monde ne marquent ce
monde à sa présence à ces actes et pas
ses actions
quinze minutes pour parler d'immortalité
j'ai déjà refusé deux minutes je crois
il me reste donc plus que 13 minutes
pour parler d'un sujet immortel avant de
parler du matin et je vous parlais de
bassam
une somme à bassam ans j'ai la chance je
passais une chance mais je suis née un
jour de mois dit à une année pas loin
d'ici
je respire donc l'air de bassanne depuis
ma naissance
donc je suis heureuse qu'il soit à
bassam le bassam dont je vous parlais
elle se bat sam là aussi le bassin de la
mer le bassam de l'eau le bassam des
voyages les bassam des rencontres
l'ensemble des allers et des venues de
bassam des vagues
oui c'est ça mon bassam aussi à moi ce
bassam du commencement du recommencement
qui nous installer répondent d'éternité
tout en sachant que nous sommes de
pauvres mortels
et puis il ya ce bassam que j'aime
beaucoup ce vieux pont ne suppose
symbole ce point qui nous racines dans
l'histoire ce pot qu'il nous rappelle
que les femmes au marché qu'elles ont
vaincu qu'elles ont gagné le point de la
victoire c'est la victoire de l'humain
sur le temps la preuve ce point est
toujours là pour marquer il nous
rappelle qu'un jour de décembre 1949 des
femmes au marché
ils ont parcouru ce pont mais qui à la
fois un pont qui relie bassam le vieux
bassam de cattier france ce pont qui
nous rapproche ce pont qui nous éloigne
mais ce port qui marque à la fois
l'histoire et ce pont qu'ils nous
fichent dans le temps et que nous dit
même si nous sommes des mortels nous
traversons toujours le temps et si nous
sommes là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
d'autres avant en travers sur ce pont et
ont permis autant d'être vaincu ce
bassin ce que j'aime aussi ce sont donc
ces femmes-là 24 décembre 1949 réseau
marché elles sont faire trembler le sol
de bassam el au fait vibrer la terre de
bassam et osé défier le côlon
ce que j'aime dans ce bassam c'est le
bassam des audacieuse des femmes qui
risquent leur vie pour sauver l'amour
parce que oui la femme est amour et qu'à
la femme est amour et donne naissance à
la vis c'est cela vaincre aussi le temps
7la s'inscrit dans l'éternité
c'est là s'inscrit dans l'immortalité
nourrissait elles sont toutes mortes ses
fans le marchand 49
mais nous sommes un peu de leurs
héritiers un peu de leurs héritiers et
ses bébés poursuivre la vie
cela pour moi aussi des mortalités
donner la vie à la vie qui elle même
donne la vie à la ville qui elle-même
continue de donner la vie c'est cela ce
beau bébé qui dort et qui porte la vie
en lui c'est ça mon bassam à moi aussi
le bassin l'immortel le bassin
maternelle et puis bassam c'est aussi
cela le temps qui passe le tas qui est
passé il manquerait ce maudit minutes le
temps qui passe nous sommes ici depuis
13 heures le temps passe et il est
bientôt 18 heures on a pensé l'arrêter
nous avons la technologie nous avons
remporté nos espoirs nous avons dit nos
espérances à la vie mais le temps lui il
est passé et le temps qui passe le voilà
qui laisse des marques sur nous-mêmes ce
temps on ne peut pas l'arrêter
que faisons nous pour l'arrêter quand il
peut agir et susurre nous se laisser
vieillir se laisser porter par le temps
et vivent avec sérénité
j'aime bien ce vieux monsieur qui est
très sûr et que nous à gages à garder
l'espoir et l'espérance à la vie et puis
chez bassam c'est aussi cela parce qu'au
bout du processus nous naissons nous
vieillissons nous mouvons vous nous
rappelle que des mortels
oui nous sommes des mortels mais moi ce
à quoi je rêve c'est non pas de ne pas
mourir mais de mourir sans mourir de
mourir elle est à présent la vie d'être
enterrée médoc au-delà de ces tombes des
dans la terre de la faconde et de la
nourrir
mais d'aller au delà parce que de mon
vivant
j'aurais été assez vivante pour marquer
mon temps et que mourir ce n'est pas
être enterrée dans cette belle tome de
mourir c'est continue à vivre est vive
vous l'avez tous ti s'est laissé des
marques laissé des traces fait des
gestes posés d'esat mener des actions
est présent ag oui mourir
cette plume est magnifique et les
légères et les fines un petit souffle et
elle s'envole mais cette plume pour moi
c'est le symbole de ce qui peut-être
laissé comme trace de vie de l'humain si
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour nous
souvenir de ces marches de grand-bassam
de 49
c'est parce que des gens ont pris leur
plume pour écrire les légères la plume
at elle écrit
elle a le poids de l'histoire est là le
poids de l'immortalité
elle a le poids de l'intemporalité elle
a le poids de la temporalité
c'est cela la plume et criait laissé des
marques laissé des traces
écrit par essence un tu me fout les
boules
écrire pour arracher la vie à la mort
écrit pour affirmer son engagement à
vivre oui tu me fout les boules
vous avez 50 ans vous avez passez donc
votre temps aller à l'école
fallait le faire c'était bien vous avez
construit votre vie en dix ans
maintenant je sais qu'à temps j'essaie
mais assez de grain
je vais récolter le fruit de ce que j'ai
subi
et puis non on vous en offre vous avez
un cancer vous faites quoi vous laisser
mourrez vous vous accrochez la vie pour
moi écrit c'était ça et clips
m'approchais la vie mais surtout écrit
pour dire mon refus de mourir et c'est
cela l'immortalité refusé de mourir
c'est déjà être immortel refusé le seul
ace vente par le cancer c'est déjà être
immortel dans des pays comme le nôtre où
le mot cancer rime avec mort il est
évident que résister au cancer ca
s'inscrit dans une forme d'immortalité
mais surtout écrit est clé pour que
d'autres demain plus supporter
l'insupportable écrire
pour dit oui le cancer l'a peut-être vu
mais il ne m'a pas vécu parce que je lui
ai foutu les boums
il me les a foutu cebula lui je lui ai
dit oui tu me fout les boules
et moi j ai je vais continuer à vivre
écrit cet important écrit parce que
écrit nous permet 2 résiste au temps
aujourd'hui nous étudions montesquieu
dans nos universités
nous étudions à 10 en or ou dans nos
universités nos étudiants ahmadou
kourouma dans nos universités
nous sommes fiers de dire que bernard
dadié centenaire mais si l'art et ce dès
demain de benhadj quais du bassin c'est
parce qu'il aura écrit pas parce qu'il
n'en veut plus entend donc pour moi
l'immortalité n'ai pas le temps que nous
passons sur ses terres c'est ce que nous
faisons de notre vie souhaitait qu'elle
soit brève qu'elle soit longue
qu'elle soit dans ce qu'ils soient
riches qu'ils soient pauvres mais
qu'elle soit une vie marquée par une
présence qui s'assume en tant que être
inscrit dans le temps mais être bien
conscient à ce que le temps qui passe et
qui lui appartient il peut en fait c'est
que le fus et j'aime bien d'ailleurs
cette citation de cette chanteuse
américaine joan baez que j'aime beaucoup
qui nous dit ceci vous n'aurez pas le
loisir de choisir quand et comment vous
allez mourir mais vous pouvez décider de
comment vous voulez vivre
[Applaudissements]
et c'est cela pour moi une mortalité
l'immortalité ce n'est pas de ne pas
mourir c'est de mourir sans mourir
ces deux parties tout en restant c'est
de laisser beaucoup de soin derrière soi
c'est d'assumer son destin d'être mortel
parce que il est inscrit dans l'adn de
tous tu mets que nous sommes que dans
notre processus de vie ce qui
garantissait la mort tout ce qui est
fait entre les deux entre le moment où
nous naissons l'allemand nous vivons et
que nous mourons son dénouement qui nous
appartiennent pour nous construire pour
marquer notre présence ici sus était
alors moi ce que je vous demande ce soir
vous voulez mourir
oui vous n'avez pas le choix vous allez
mourir nous allons mourir une serre
arrêt dans la peur nous allons mourir
nous allons pleurer d'aller souffrir
nous allons pleurer parce que de l'être
cher nous quitte et qu'il parte mais oui
nous allons mourir mais l'autre question
c'est est-ce que vous mourrez et que
vous mourrez définitivement ou est-ce
que vous mourrez vous continuez à vivre
éternellement
cela dépend de nous vivre ou mourir
j'ai choisi moi de mourir ou de vivre à
la fois de mourir et de vivre en même
temps de mourir tout en vivant et de
vivre sans mourir parce que cela est
possible
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]